you know what's funny after watching
cabin in the woods I watch movies like
this with new eyes chernobyl Diaries or
as it should be called the hill skis
have eyes of each so in the true noble
diaries a few friends want to go see the
sights I want to explore this place
course is going to be some radioactive
freaks you saw that in the trailer yeah
and that's pretty much what it's about
these these people are trapped they're
running from the radioactive people who
still live there on that it's exactly
how you think it's going to be the
movies absurdly predictable you're like
this is gonna happen now this is going
to happen I saw that in the trailer this
is going to happen funny thing is when I
saw the trailer I thought okay another
found footage movie but it's actually
not one of those found footage movies
that surprised me I was glad of it I was
like okay I've seen a lot of those found
footage movies Chronicle pretty much
capped on that we've seen it done in a
lot of horror movies so I was glad that
it wasn't yet another found footage
movie just looks like it because someone
films it with a shaky cam the entire
time yeah it's hard to see what's going
on there's another annoying thing about
the movie when things are actually
attacking people the cameras just doing
this or like I I don't know they could
be getting attacked by beetles not not
the life form like the bang I wouldn't
know it this movie does have that
anxiety feeling I'll give the movie that
you know long dark hallways one
flashlight you feel like you're playing
Silent Hill or the first Resident Evil
for the first time only you're watching
it among the intensity in the movie like
there's a scene where this chick gets
dragged away and they're going after her
but you hear her voice coming from
there's a lot of hallways it was just
echo and they don't know where to go and
I was putting myself in their shoes and
I was like I wouldn't know where to go
either I'd feel really guilty like I
felt like I just killed that check what
a movie can do that that's not a bad
thing that's actually what they're
supposed to do in these situations other
than that you've seen this movie a
hundred times before it's like we need
just a few teenagers to die in a movie
what hasn't been done yet oh Chernobyl
perfect we'll do that I already did the
whole Nick thing in Nevada let's do the
radiation injure Noble don't worry my
Japanese friends your times probably
coming soon and the acting is not good
there are some scenes really like yeah
you're lucky you chicks are hot and
that's what happens when you have a
singer in a movie even a horror movie
that doesn't really require a lot of
acting yeah it's apparent early on these
people are in this movie simply to die
at a point I was like oh there's only
four people it's not a lot of people to
watch gets slaughter and then two other
people come in they're like hey can we
join the tour with you I was like oh
okay there's the cannon fodder these
people have
now entered the movies simply to die
which I understand you need in a movie
like this but don't think it's a
blatantly obvious but my statement about
cabin in the woods still stands after
you see cabin in the woods you look at
movies like this and you're like yeah
the formula that they spelled out in
cabin in the woods is exactly how this
is going down in this movie I'm telling
you man behind the scenes these two guys
were pulling the strings that's the end
of the movie what's happening I was like
okay if it wraps up well if it has a
good ending I'll bump it up a great no I
hated the ending it was [ __ ] so you know
can't do that I mean I credit the movie
with a nice creepy vibe and a couple of
intense scenes but in the end it's ok
but you're not gonna remember it t-minus
one day yep already forgot it's nothing
special you get out of the movie theater
you move on to whatever else you have
going on in your life now I've noticed
that some people are really pissed this
movie got made because Lauren Noble was
a huge disaster it was a tragedy I can't
believe they made a movie like this
about it making a slasher flick out of a
tragedy that's just unconscionable
[ __ ] I would say don't even worry
about it we live in a world where we
have movies about nazi zombies of the SS
the fact that movies like that exist
doesn't take away from the tragedy of
the Holocaust the fact that chernobyl
Diaries exist doesn't take away from the
tragedy of the Chernobyl meltdown
someone just saw an opportunity to make
a cheap horror flick and they did it
it's not the first horror flick to come
out of a tragedy or disaster it's not
going to be the last I mean there are
things worth getting worked up about in
the world chernobyl Diaries not one of
them so now that we're done with that
soap box yeah chernobyl Diaries not
worth watching so what's your favorite
oh the creepy people are coming after us
and they're gonna kill us and that's we
have to survive probably not going to
movie whatever it is comment below let
me know and as always even like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you